Speaker 1: So what makes it so unique in your eyes, what you are doing with your team?
Speaker 2: The idea is to be open, I think open for looking for interesting solutions in nature and the approach,
probably quite unique still from my group, but I think it becoming more and more popular, is,
we have two directions of how we look at nature.
One is, let's say there's an interesting creature doing something amazing,
and we are trying to learn the- what is happening and maybe apply it.
That's one approach, and apply it maybe to different things.
But even more interesting, it's just emerging now, is that instead of looking for one creature that tells us something,
what if we take lessons from completely different organisms?
They have nothing in common, they have different environments, but one can teach something,
but it's not enough for certain purpose.
Together with yet another organism, you can learn something else,
and combining lessons from completely different organisms that evolve their things for their specific needs,
then to solve a certain problem.
So that's a really interesting approach, is really take small lessons from different, from plants,
from brittle stars because I have research where I combine lessons from this creature with this,
so they have nothing in common. That one taught us something, this one taught us something.
Combining them together, we produce a new technology that would never appear if we wouldn't combine these two lessons.
So the idea of combining different creatures-
Speaker 1: What will [inaudible 00:02:07] combined from the two?	So can you explain what did you learn of these two?
Speaker 2: So you probably know who are starfish and sea urchins.
So this is the closest relative of both, so it's also you see his five folds in his ray of the body,
just like a starfish, but it's called brittle star. Its arms are called brittles, it's very fast.
You see it's black, and it's already dead of course, but during the day, it's black and during the night, it is white.
And the way it changes color is by introducing inside the, its skeleton,
black pigment that covers the lens just like some glasses that change color when there's too much light.
This is what this organism does, and makes light reception dynamic depending how much light outside,
so that's the lesson from here. This one has structural color, so this blue is structural color.
Structural color means that it's not chemical color.
It's not coming from pigment, it's coming from arrangement of peaches.
It's coming purely from distances between peaches in this structure.
So depending how close they are, it would be the blue or green, so it has almost nothing to do with the material.
I can get blue color in any material by just making it in their regular array. Now this color is not dynamic.
It's not changing in any way, so we can combine the idea of how liquid here changes color of this organism,
and introduce this liquid as an active element into structures that would make very similar to that butterfly.
Result of that is that we put together new technology where the color can change as a function of infiltration of a
liquid, but then we use this for very interesting applications.
We're looking how that concept was liquid, suddenly changes color in different ways,
and I will probably show you a couple of those things in the lab.
We can use that as sensor, we can use it for encryption because, there's certain messages can be written there,
and you will never see them. We actually have a butterfly with tattoo.
The tattoo is coming out, only one you expose to a liquid and that gives us a way to have hidden messages.
Logos that would appear only when you expose it to right liquid.
So the oral idea of dynamic materials is in this particular case, by combining these strategies,
but we have many more examples of one organism teaches something, and the other one teaches a little bit more,
and together, it's interesting.
Speaker 1: And you apply it to materials in a way?
Speaker 2: Yes, so we're making now, and we're actually making, I actually have a lot of them,
but most of them are in design school because I use them for teaching, but we'll see some of them in my lab,
where you will see it looks exactly like this beautiful blue color, but it's actually material that we make,
but compared to this.
As simple as, imagine a shot glass that has beautiful color, and depending on what you drink,
it will give you different messages that you don't know really existed.
So simple way to make it beautiful, but in fact, we can use it.
In particular, we're working with department of transportation to design it into a sensor for detection of oil quality,
so in North Dakota, they're pulling out a lot of oil. There is no pipe line, and they're transporting it by rail.
And within the last couple of years,
there were a lot of explosions because oil was not properly labeled by what type of oil that is.
So to have a very simple detector that has beautiful color and depending on the quality of oil,
this oil would either infiltrate it or not, and therefore the color will change in certain ways.
As a very simple, you don't need to use fancy equipment, it's almost pregnancy tests or pH paper..
You put it in oil and you know what quality it is in which container you need to pack it so ..
Speaker 1: So you learn from nature, from animals or plants, or organisms?
Speaker 2: Yup.
Speaker 1: You learn from their characteristics or from their, what their, if you go deeper into,
what biologies normally do.
Speaker 2: That's right, so I don't call it by a mimicry, because I'm not mimicking nature, it is by inspired science.
So I use it as an inspiration, and things that I make are not necessarily even used the same way nature used it,
often for completely different application.
It's just certain design principles that nature has evolved,
become very interesting approaches that one can use for smart materials design.
So it is not mimicking nature, it is taking lessons inspired by nature, and think where we can use these beyond,
well beyond what nature is doing.
And also, we can't, at this moment, mimic the entire complexity of natural system, and probably I don't want to.
So the butterfly and this sea urchins, they need to multiply, they need to do all kinds of things.
If I'm making a device, let's say, to detect quality of oil, I don't need all of these features.
So being able to extract from nature.
So to take these principles, and simplify them sometimes,
or reformulate them in such a way that it can be used somewhere else. This is what we actually do.
Speaker 1: In a way, evolution already chose the best way of having organisms.
Speaker 2: I may not agree with that, I'm not sure that evolution always makes the best choice.
In a sense that there is always local pressures, local environmental conditions and often,
nature has the materials stuck with certain choices that is very expensive to change.
And then, within that range, so I would say that, my logical solutions are often sub-optimal. Not optimal.
We have our ideas, why? In particular, published in a number of papers.
So if we look, we got this paper that was actually describing how this organism changes color, but it's a skeleton,
so nature often does something we do not do yet, which is designing one material for multiple purposes.
So, often natural design might not be best for each of the purposes it has to serve,
but it does it very well for multiple things.
For example, if I design lenses, and these are lenses on top of a skeleton,
maybe I'll design lenses in a different way, and better than these in a different material,
but the same material is supposed to be a skeleton.
So it's not just optically perfect, it has to be structurally perfect.
So neither of them are probably perfect, but to think about one material that can do both things well enough,
then evolution finds the best solution for that.
And sometimes we'll look at this optimization, there are so many parameters you need to optimize for,
maybe there are some that we don't even know about, and then what we can say, flaws of evolution.
It's not perfect, it could be done better. Maybe not, because the material is supposed to do many other things.
For example, multiply, dissolve at certain moment, and then our regular approaches of why not to make it out glass,
why not to make it out of metal, will not be applicable, and therefore not used in nature.
So multi-functionality is a very interesting approach.
Speaker 1: So what you are doing is creating next nature in a way.
Speaker 2: I don't know, but I would say that.
I would just say that maybe there are creatures that already have these features,
but what we are trying to do is combine unrelated lessons from different organisms together to solve an interesting
societal problem,
some interesting technical problem to create a new material that can do something that our current materials can't do.
So it is not next nature, but I would say it's next generation of advanced materials.
Materials that respond to environment, so why can't we have our buildings that either breathe,
or shut the wettability depending whether it's the rain outside or not.
Why can't we have our entire windows that would, in a smart way, which means in response to temperature outside,
to light outside, change the performance to let the light through or not.
There is so many things that if we consider general lessons from nature that we haven't yet, understood very well,
which is responsiveness, which is adaptive nature and ability to reconfigure, adjust.
If we would have materials of that kind, that would be a really interesting move for technology.
Speaker 1: What's the thing where you are now the most proud of if you apply to material?
Speaker 2: That's a tough question.
I have a very big group, and in a way, each of these projects is my baby,
so you don't ask which baby you don't like most out of your kids.
Each of them, in some ways, satisfies different parts of what is important to me.
If you would ask what is the most interesting science, it's one part of that.
I don't even often, in this case, as question, is it going to be useful, is just to uncover interesting mechanisms
and ideas and what nature does in interesting ways.
And there are a couple of things where we are proud of in this direction.
For example, to understand the structure of this plant.
So to understand that the organism was able to create a fiber-optical network, and a beautiful skeleton of glass,
and fully explain how this is structurally, and from materials point of view, is design and is architecture.
That's, I'm proud of. I also like, in this direction, ability to grow pretty much any crystal I want.
We may look at some of them in the microscope later on just to grow flowers that are just size of human hair
or smaller that, but in any shape or form.
So that to understand them, the lengths, I am so well that we can do it, so I am very proud of that part.
Now the other side though, is that is we do not just science purpose, but coming not from science
and then thinking where one can use it, but to do it the other way around, starting with a problem
and think how one can solve it.
So these are more technology or application oriented studies and there, and the ones that I'm most proud of, probably,
are the two developments that have happened in my group in the last five, six years. And these are two technologies.
One is based on inspiration coming from pitcher plant where we really developed completely new family of materials that
can be designed in a very simple way at this moment.
We can make it in metal, polymer and glass, and any material but the material that would repel, what you want to repel,
it would repel ice, it would repel barnacles and mussels.
It would repel blood, it would repel bacteria, and to create the family of [inaudible 00:17:41] materials.
Very proud of this work, and I'm very proud of work of where we can use self-assembled materials and structural color,
actually, as sensors, as a way to detect and reveal how materials are exposed to environment,
so these are two that are related to applications there.
The overall idea for that came from, we want to solve a problem, of let's say, fouling.
What should we do, which organism should we look at to help us do it.
So not from the organisms to application, but rather from application to organisms and natural system that can help.
Speaker 1: And when you look at it, we can create- there is an endless future of possibilities in your science.
It's like, a whole new world's opening by looking at biology in this way,
and then thinking about characteristics that can be used in other materials.
Speaker 2: I agree. The, I hope that there would be more and more studies of this kind.
It's just a good example of that is our recent paper, actually published this year in nature,
was on making the most efficient ethics changes, the most efficient water collection systems,
and the way we designed it was combining lessons from three different natural systems,
where we were looking on how to optimize three parameters, all of them orthogonal to each other, very different,
and combining these three organisms gave us the best solution.
Nothing in technology works as well as that, so we combine lessons from desert beetle, from cactus
and from pitcher plant and we're able to put together something interesting that neither of them alone will teach us.
Now how many of these capabilities? I'm sure it's endless.
There's so many organisms,
and there are so many things about organisms that nobody has studied yet in endless combination of something that
nature evolved here, because it was important for this organism,
and somewhere else because it was important for another organism, together it gives unusual,
unexpected solution that nobody can easily come up with that concept,
so it's not generally obvious.	We are not trying to go and to try to do the obvious science, it's uneven,
untraditional, unorthodox combinations that we're trying to do.
Speaker 1: And where did it all start for you?
When did your passion for looking at nature, looking at it, where did it start?
Speaker 2: I can't even remember, I think it was always there.
I guess in some ways, there's a little bit of unpleasant beginning of all that when I was a child,
when I was two years old.
It all started when I went to kindergarten, and my nurse in the kindergarten by mistake,
gave me triple dose of vaccine for anti-polio vaccine, at that time, vaccine was alive
and I actually was paralyzed for a number of years.
So when I was paralyzed, I was in the sanatorium, on the black sea and was exposed to shells, to waves,
to black sea at that time.
They were unpleasant times, but at the same time, it was the time when all the kids were running around and playing
and I was in a chair and that was the beginning of looking, observing nature and loving it, really.
Then in school, I guess that, so I was, winner of all the mathematical Olympias,
so science was always something I wanted to do.
It was never a question of which science, but I guess that my parents, who were very influential for me,
we constantly had discussions and some fights between them, whether I would follow my dad's steps or my mom's steps,
and I decided to combine both.
My mom was a medical doctor, specifically interested in infectious diseases,
and I do now a lot of work in making materials from medical devices that prevent infections that prevent bacteria to
form, and my dad is a structural engineers.
He always wanted me to be an engineer, and this combination is actually really interesting, and I guess that's,
as I mentioned, I can track it back a time when I was three or four years old.
Speaker 1: Yeah, and then looking at the shells when you were in this chair,
in what way- that was the only thing you could, do of course. You could see the sea, you could smell the sea.
Speaker 2: That's right. I'm sorry.
What always interested me, and it's something that probably, I keep doing it 'til now, is pattern information.
It's not only seashells, let's say, but the, how waves leave interesting signs on the sand.
So these rhombii in the patterns left behind by the waves on the sand was my obsession for a very long time.
So since I was most interested in mathematics as a student in school,
I actually thought that I would be applied mathematician, but then I was convinced that by doing physical chemistry,
I could still do a lot of mathematics, but I can also do physics, chemistry, and biology,
and it was quite a convincing augment to get to the Moscow university to the chemistry department.
So it's patterned information, how different features form and many things in my research, in particular,
patterns in these photonic crystals, or patterns on this sponge, if you see, probably,
that the patterns on this sponge are extremely-
Speaker 1: Can you get it a bit closer for the camera?
Speaker 2: So if you look at that, it's not living anymore, but it's a natural sponge, it's fully, this skeleton of it,
it's fully made of glass, just like we make our buildings and our windows, but I hope, you see,
that in addition to just beautiful glass architecture, it is still irregular.
It has something like a chessboard structure, so there's one window and another one is closed, and it's, again,
pattern.
I was interested when I started to look at that, how this symmetry, that can arise from a living organism,
how can it form a skeleton with such an incredible regularity.
If you look here, there are also diagonal elements running through the sponge,
and they're running exactly every four square. Every four square.
Every second square, it has a dark square, so there's an incredible regularity, so the origin of these features,
the origin of this order, is all within the, our status of how patterns, how interesting assembly works.
Speaker 1: And what did you do with the information you got from this sponge? What did you apply with it?
Did it allure you or what?
Speaker 2: So this is, there's a couple of things that we are trying to do, hopefully, is to,
what we do is we simplify this sponge design, so these are 3D printed,
and this one has all the structural elements this sponge has. This one has a little bit less, this one.
So we make different types of this structure to understand why nature ended up with this specific architecture to make
the most mechanically strong material.
So the lessons that we learn from that is how to make most mechanically strong glass that one can arrange from very
small scale to very large scale.
So then this sponge, in fact, I gave couple of lectures describing that if you look at this from every level,
I can probably teach entire class of civil engineering, and everything we use in the design, laminated materials
or fiber-enforced materials or cemented structures, everything.
Every element that we use now is actually already used by this sponge. So it's a lot of interesting things.
Whether it's additional features, in particular, hierarchy, how nature makes it from mammoth scale,
up to this macroscopic scale to avoid corns that the sponge has in the sea.
So there is a lot of interesting lessons, but again, there's lesson in multi-functionality.
This is a skeleton, but it's also, in our opinion, designed to control and optimize three functions, at least.
Which is, has to be strong, because it's skeleton,
but it also- these are optical fibers that couple light into this structure,
most of them I already removed from my research.
So the structure has to act as a beacon in the sea, so how one can use glass to make optical fibers
and also skeletons out of glass in natural conditions, not the two-thousand degree sea as we deal with glass,
but in addition to that, sponge is a primitive organism, sponges breath
and feed by pumping seawater through this openings.
All these openings in its structure is for pumping seawater, then organic particles that are coming through this body,
are uptaken and [inaudible 00:31:10] by this primitive, it's not even a- it's a multicellular organism,
but it doesn't have organs, it's nothing, it's really primitive.
However, it's able and combining optical properties, mechanical properties, and what we believe, the design,
with this nice structure of opening one pore, closing another one,
is heading served function to optimize fluidics so that it doesn't need to use too much energy to pump water through
this structure so that some windows are open more than others.
And in addition to that, I don't know how much you could see, but there are two white things inside,
you can probably maybe can get it out, maybe.
That's very sticky, so very difficult to get it out, maybe now you can see them better.
This is part of the claw of a shrimp that lives inside the sponge.	Symbiotically with the sponge,
so we learn a lot about natural symbiotic life, of how to make mechanically strong materials, and optical fibers,
and it's all designed for these shrimp to be protected from environments where nobody can catch them and eat them,
but for shrimp to be able to eat, needs food, so how would the shrimp get the food?
The optical fibers provide enough illumination so everything is attracted to light.
I would come of that, there's always feast.
So they have more than enough food, and the products of their life cycle,
so all their excrements are used by sponge for its own feeding, so really interesting ideas.
However, what if and we are thinking about it, but I'll know whether it would be, after all, the outcome of that,
but what if we look at that and we think about a future building.
So this building, this 3d printed version, has every structural element that this sponge has.
This sponge is also a building because shrimp lives inside.
But what if we would actually use the idea of energy saving ideas, the sponge has already evolved,
which is in this case, to pump water through the system, but in this case,
it could be a building where size of the openings of some of the windows would be opened for airflow for wind so that
you could have the most efficient energy balance of the building, but at the same time, mechanically,
it would have all of these diagonal elements, you can see the end, one open, one closed, so that mechanically,
it's very strong, but it's actually, on top of that, aesthetically very pleasing.
What if this building, this is lesson from sponge,
but what if this building would also have lessons that we can take from butterflies
and this building will change color due to the liquid coming through certain places and during rain,
it would reveal certain messages and you would see a dynamic color change as natural conditions change.
Or the windows, yet another project that we like,
would have this ability to control the light intensity so we really think about as not anywhere close yet,
but we think about building, that's why I'm probably coughing, because it's so far away,
but it's difficult to imagine that we're anywhere close,
but what if our future would be materials that combine smart solutions from completely different organisms,
and that gives us environments, materials,
and entire architecture that is capable of most efficient way control airflow, to control resistance of ice formation,
to control optical properties, reconfigure, change depending on which side it is.
Depending on what part of the world this building is going to be built in.
So that's, if I were to dream big, this is what I hope we can make this building out of interesting puzzles
and interesting ideas that nature has created and nature has evolved and probably waiting for us to uncover.
Speaker 1: When did you discover this sponge?
Speaker 2: Sponge, um-
Speaker 1: How did you find it?
Speaker 2: So, it's, I was very interested in sponges long time ago
when I was a student in the Weizmann Institute.	Should I- where do you want me to hold it?
Speaker 3: You can come as close as you want to the camera, it's nice for me. Yup, okay.
Speaker 2: Okay.
Speaker 1: So the glass fiber, how does that work?
Speaker 2: So this sponge, when it's alive, it's coated with a thin layer of brownish cells,
but all these windows are actually open for bumping water through it, but it's attached to ocean floor right here,
what is called holdfast apparatus, but it has multiple function.
So not only holds it inside the floor, but at the end of each of these fibers, so these are optical fibers.
There's a crown of optical fibers surrounding this bunch, just this crown is,
has the wavelengths of light associated with the bioluminescent material that lives in the ocean floor,
and the light produced by this bacteria is coupled into these fibers
and it shines really similar to these fiber-optical lens.
Speaker 1: Can you take it, 'cause I can't go there with my camera.
Speaker 2: A lot coming from bacterias, coupled to these lenses, and the end of each of these, of this fiber,
there is a lens for efficient coupling of light, and it shines very similar to these optical fibers that we all know
and we think that we invented fiberoptics just 60 years ago or so, but in fact,
this is one of the oldest organisms that exist and they knew how to make fiber-optical things back then,
so it's really the same principle, is the structure of these fibers would have a higher index core
and lower index cladding, and the signal goes through the center of the fiber and shines at the end.
It actually shines many places, because it actually shines almost like Christmas tree,
because it has major point where light coming off is on the tip that some of these fibers have branches,.
and these also highlight it due to the out-coupling of light in these [rotations 00:39:56]
Speaker 1: 'Cause it's very deep.
Speaker 2: It's deeper in the ocean, there is no sunlight there,
so the only light that is coming are from the ocean floor.
Now maybe you could see, I hope you could see, one second, there are two, here's inside this sponge,
these two wide things. If you see them, if you can focus on them, or I can try to wiggle them around.
These are claws of the shrimp that lives inside.
So one may say that, compared to shrimp that is freely swimming, it is a disadvantage because they cannot swim
and find food, but it's actually an advantage.
First advantage is pretty much nothing can crunch this extremely strong material, so the mechanic will protect it.
There is no enemies, really, for the shrimp. They may want to, but they cannot crash the glass.
Now food comes from the fact that this is, as a fiber-optical lamp, it's enough light in this area,
in the ocean so that anything living is always attracted to light,
and the density of food that the shrimp can eat is pretty high, and in this way,
it is a nice combination of symbiotic life between bioluminescent material, sponge, and the shrimp that lives inside
and none of them alone would be able to survive especially in the conditions where there is almost no light
and food is really depleted as you go deeper and deeper in the ocean,
but together it produces a very interesting system.
So that's how we think about new materials, new designs of combining things together
and thinking how different organisms can teach us something that current materials or current devices don't use yet..
Just because it's, you see how- [inaudible 00:42:40]
I wouldn't recommend fetching this to you up close because it would immediately attack.
It's amazing, it's another feature, it has an incredible ability better than velcro to attach anything.
Speaker 1: So could you, you have three labs.
Speaker 2: Yes. I have one lab in three different locations.
Speaker 1: Okay, and when you describe the three different locations, what are the differences?
Speaker 2: So the difference really, I would still probably prefer everything to be in one location,
so that people talk to shells, that even a lot, we almost have a lot of activities together.
In some ways, it's divided by topics, maybe.
Not many topics, but generally speaking, I would say in my lab, the lab that is here in the engineering building,
there's a lot of projects that are related to dynamic materials to self-assembly to making colorful materials,
responsive materials, and it has a lot of work with more than pigments, optical devices, and so on.
It's one lab, thinking about the ways one can, for example, just another paper that was on the cover of a journal,
How to Make Materials Assemble, absolutely interesting patterns.
So that is in one lab, and it's very generally described, I would say, as self-assembly and dynamic response materials,
a lot of synthesis is done in this lab.
My, another lab is doing a lot of research in filing materials, but specifically, more biological materials,
so using pitcher plant as an inspiration to make materials that repel ice,
materials that can be used in heat exchanges, prevent fouling, generally, but it's a lot of studies of what is it,
why they people like that, what would be the fundamental science and physical
and chemical principles to understand which one should do, talk to my stem, where does performance come from,
and it's really fluidics and materials' characterization related to wetting phenomenon.
Will these surfaces, will these structures that may be wet by different media.
And the third lab is somewhat related to second, but it's more on biological fouling.
So not necessarily fouling, it would be a wrong thing to say fouling. I would say by a, NANA interfaces.
So in some cases, we want to repel things, for example, we want to repel bacteria, we want to repel mussels
and barnacles from ships in the ocean, but in other cases,
it could be to create materials on which we can harvest algae for [anaegic 00:46:48] production, but it's again,
there's a lot of questions one can ask.
One you need to harvest them so they feel comfortable,
but then you need to have ways to release them from the structures and surfaces that are used for their production,
so the third lab is mostly related to growing bacterial cultures, growing algae in the laboratory solutions,
laboratory conditions, and identifying the structure, how they interact with materials that we make
and to really come up with recipes for different applications.
So one can say that we have a general approach that we learned from the pitcher plant.
It's what's called platform technology.
I's really, there are parts of that that can be combined in different ways,
depending whether you want to do it on glass or on metal, and depending whether you want to repel marine things,
we want to repel ice so one can use it as a system design with different components depending what you want to do
and we study a lot, how different combinations of materials together give the best outcome for specific target..
Speaker 1: It's so strange that we, you, or other scientists .. [inaudible 00:48:29]
Speaker 2: Oh my god, you are very sensitive.
Speaker 3: His microphone is sensitive. I'm less sensitive.
Speaker 2: Well, that's interesting, a cough, but it's, a lot of it's a real endurement. There are cars.
Speaker 1: But it's so strange, when you look for metal, that metal and corrosion.
Speaker 2: There's some things, obviously. Now I'm becoming sensitive.
Speaker 3: We're almost done here. That's good, that's good.
Speaker 1: They're like metal and corrosion which we accepted for tens of, hundreds of years or more,
that you've found this material that you could prove only that it changes.
It's so strange that now we are finding these and not earlier.
Speaker 2: That's true, but I think that we will make a lot of interesting, we as a science in general,
and not talking about my lab only.
If we open our eyes and think in the very non-traditional terms about what we can learn from nature,
we can suddenly realize there are many interesting solutions that we have no idea exist,
and many of them in fact are extremely simple.
In particular, the pitcher plant idea is very simple, but it is counter-intuitive, so if we talk about it and
when I'm trying to explain the system, when I say it's counter-intuitive,
because everything is against the rules that are commonly used in current technologies and well-established rules.
For example, if we think about how to make a material that has as little friction as possible, so the way we do it now,
we polish everything.
We polish so that the surface has a minimum number of defects, because every defects produces friction.
So if we talk about pipes, everything is polished, because otherwise they would create turbulence
when we transport oil or water.
If anywhere else, if we think about the materials that need to get to lowest friction as possible,
we need to get rid of roughness.
Now what pitcher plant is doing is that it actually creates an extremely rough surface.
It is extremely structured surface, which by all laws of physics,
is supposed to be extremely bad if you wanted to produce friction for your material.
However, it is high friction when it's dry, so that ants
or insects are capable of moving around on the surface of this pitcher plant, on a dry day,
being hap- having no idea what may happen when there is rain, but what happens
when there is rain is that this structured surface picks up water because it's hydrophilic, it likes water,
and by picking up water, it creates layer over layer of a liquid that is trapped inside the structure solid.
The outcome of that that you have a structured material, a rough material, but the roughness has a second role.
Its role is to hold water, and at the end, what insects would experience is not the rough surface,
you use rough surface to create ultra smooth surface because your final outcome is the surface of water,
and liquid has no defects.
So that's why I'm saying it's counterintuitive, because we use roughness to get rid of roughness in a way,
and also we use liquid as a material. There is not that many places where liquid can be considered as a material.
It could be used, let's say in 3d printing or anywhere else, to make something out of it,
but the final outcome is a solid. So materials are solids. In this case, liquid is part of it.
Together with solid, it makes a new concept. Liquid alone doesn't do it, solid alone doesn't do it.
But combining these together gives an interesting outcome
and that's why I'm saying it's counterintuitive because we use roughness to get rid of roughness,
and we use liquids stored in a way inside structured surfaces that hold it nicely inside to take advantage of liquids
that otherwise cannot be shaped, cannot, they won't run away.
But now they're inside your material, and they lend the material with its properties.
So this is brittle star, used to have five arms, I just removed one arm for analysis.
So it changes color, not all brittle stars do that but this species does, and during the day it's black.
And the reason it's black during the day is that it has lenses on its surface that regulate the light intensity
depending how much light outside and the receptors under the lens can work only in certain range.
So when it's too bright, they cover the lens with a black pigment
and therefore the entire organism changes color to black, and at night, when actually they are active species,
they are doing everything at night, when it's not enough light, they withdraw the pigment back into the structure,
opening the lenses for more efficient collection of light,
so the color change here is due to the dynamic nature of bringing a liquid in, in this case, pigment,
and then withdrawing it back.
So the idea of bringing liquids in into materials is now a very common theme in many of my projects
and some of them are completely unrelated but it's thinking about liquids in and on materials.
Speaker 1: One question about that brittle fish- why is it during the day, why black and not white, I should say.
Speaker 2: So it's not mimicry, it's not mimicking the environment, and in fact, this is what the beginning,
biological literature was using this as another example of mimicking the environment
and changing the color accordingly. It's actually opposite of what you would expect, and that was a big mistake.
That was what attracted me to this topic, is it's not hiding.
Because it's just being even better seen during the day, and even more so during the night.
The function here is to optimize light collection and therefore during night, you want to get rid of pigment,
and during the day, you want to screen your lenses from excessive light.
So it's not mimicking the color of the environment, it's optimizing its technology, which is in this case,
dynamic lenses.
Speaker 1: That's exactly what you are doing, and biologists is not [inaudible 00:57:02]
Speaker 2: That's correct, so biologists always look for common, they are comfortable, terminology that they used to,
suddenly to tell the story, but no, the entire color change has a completely different function,
and it's to optimize and improve the performance of optical elements, and it's optics, it's not on the skeleton,
and overall thinking that skeleton can also be an optical element is really interesting idea.
Think about buildings that, of course, mechanically strong,
but also have built-in optical structure so the same construction is actually its own optical element that collects
light or reflects light, so it's pretty interesting.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
Sort of the difference between you and a biologist is that when you look at the animals and the organisms,
you look at the characteristics or the functions?
Speaker 2: I say I look more for, if I may say, high-tech properties.
If it's, I'm less interested,
although it's extremely important to understand what are the specific cellular mechanisms that are involved in making
the specific biological structures or what is the biological cell or biology or proteins
or polysaccharides that are involved in these functions. I am more interested in technology.
I'm more interested in devices that became an outcome of the evolution that performed high-tech function,
so I'm interested in mechanics, I'm interested in optics, and I'm interest- but optics beyond eyes.
We're not all about our eyes because we need to know about it, but other interesting optical solutions,
and I'm looking for magnetic structures in nature, how nature makes magnetic materials that are different from us,
so it's really, I would say technical characteristics of biological materials.
Speaker 1: When you look in near future, where are we humans with our technological brain
and technological possibility, where are we going to?
Speaker 2: That's a tough question.
I'm not sure I can say where we're going, I can tell you what I feel would be very important
and what I feel really interesting and which area would be to create technologies,
materials that have the ability to self-assemble, self-assemble,
it uses environment as a trigger for behavioral changes, not to overuse energies,
every time everything is run by hinges, by chain you switch on and off, they may have and this is what organisms do
and I hope the future might be,
to create a range of interesting materials that know how to switch behavior from letting sun in or not, from being,
from accepting water to repelling water. Because in some cases, one is too dry, you really want the water to come in.
You want the building to breathe, but when it's extremely wet, and there's rain every day,
you actually want to repel it,
so how can one create the same material that will change its own function in response to what happens outside?
I think this is the future, it might take on the future.
Speaker 1: Our program is cool to the mind of the universe,
the idea that it's our barriers in accessibility to knowledge are going down through the internet where you're born
and you can learn everything about quantum mechanics.
What do you think about that, have we somehow created cognosphere around our biosphere?
Speaker 2: That's a difficult question.
I watch my grandson, he's almost six years old, but even when he was two,
he was already trying to look on the cellphone and he knew how to move things around and that you,
and he at certain moment, he came to our TV and was trying to open window on the TV and TV was,
he was so surprised that it's not doing it, so there are problems,
maybe with the fact that you don't even need to learn anything, you can have access to any information,
any moment you want it.
However, at the same time, I still hope that there is something that these days, is easier to do than before,
and I hope that we will benefit from that and this is multidisciplinarity, in a way.
So I'm physical chemist by training.
Not an engineer, I'm not a biologist, I'm not a medical doctor, so then I'm a physical chemist.
However, I do a lot of physics, math, architecture and biology and medicine research.
Why that is possible,
is that I feel that none of these disciplines alone are capable of addressing tomorrow's questions adequately,
or have the tools to do it in the most efficient way.
So I feel that when I combine in my group, I try to bring mathematicians, physicists, chemists, medical doctors
and designers together, the goal for that is to think about the way these people would address science in unusual ways.
Just to give you a very simple demonstration of that,
if one wants to describe why this butterfly has these beautiful colors, actually, you pretty much need to know optics.
Physics and optics alone will describe what is happening for this butterfly.
However, all our technological changes, all the improvements that we had, were due to the fact that- okay,
we understand optics.
But what if I now use my chemistry knowledge and I encrypt chemical information inside this structure?
What if now, this optical device would have different chemistries in different locations.
So without chemistry, pretty much anything that we've done with this material, would be absolutely impossible.
Suddenly, chemistry gave a nice spread of applications and possibilities that optics, physics alone couldn't do.
Chemistry alone also couldn't do it, so chemistry with physics, with optics, gave an interesting outcome,
but then yet another area, having a fluid mechanicist in my group,
brought the ideas of how liquids would infiltrate these structures, can move around in interesting ways,
and in this way to create interesting unusual changes in color in response to environment, so in my opinion,
it's very important for kids, for our future, still have very clearly depth in some traditional disciplines.
I would, if I were now to have a high school student choosing what to do, I would say,
begin with choosing one discipline that you will learn very deeply as your first degree.
But then, especially for those who are interested in science and will stay in science, I as a PhD, work
or I would then create teams of different backgrounds coming together
and learning something from another community that you alone wouldn't know otherwise,
so this bringing together expertise, is, I think, the future, and I hope that we will see more and more papers
and technologies that were a clear outcome of multiple disciplines contributing to the aural design.